the pile of ash is already a meter high
for weeks workers from this brittany
fish factory have been protesting as
planned closure
after years of service they suddenly
face the bleak prospect of redundancy
it's a disaster for this region the
center of brittany
we've already lost a lot of food
factories and if they close this one too
the whole area will collapse
denise castell is one of at least 200
workers at marine harvest
although it's an important regional
employer the promise of cheaper labor
costs is enough to lure operations
eastwards to poland workers t-shirts
read we are angry and given the fact
that the company has just paid its
shareholders 35 million in dividends
their anger is justified they're
fighting for fair compensation
in france there are those on the top and
those at the bottom those at the top
just ignore us so we're protesting
especially in brittany because people
here are very attached to their
the
region
have spread far beyond the factory walls
the nearby town of carre is a wash with
posters claiming solidarity for the
workers cause
they often depict the bonner rouge or
red caps which are a throwback to
brittany's 17th century revolt against
paris and the introduction of a new tax
christian tredek the mayor of curry is
the face of the contemporary red caps
he's in great demand among the french
media and is increasingly drawing the
attention of other international news
outlets
the stagnant political situation in
paris is making brittany's protests more
effective
it was not sarkozy but hollande who won
the 2012 presidential elections
it is not that hollande was promising
much but voters hoped there would be
some degree of change
but absolutely nothing has changed
except the constant introduction of new
taxes
a new tax on heavy goods vehicles known
as the eco tax was the straw that broke
brittany's back
arguing that such a levy would
disadvantage far-flung regions such as
brittany locals rebelled
in early november tens of thousands of
people turned out to a demonstration in
the regional capital camper even though
the government hastily postponed the
introduction of the tax
such protests make the government
nervous but the next big one is planned
for the end of the month
jan manach will be there
he and christian troydek have fought
political battles together in the past
is a dairy farmer and cheese producer
his is a typically britain business but
like many other farmers he's worried
about the agricultural crisis in
brittany and about his future
everyone is talking about the crisis in
the agricultural industry
but at the moment it is a crisis for
manufacturers
our profits now barely even cover our
costs
and so he dons the red cap in protest
he says european enlargement is part of
the problem as brittany simply can't
compete with cheap eastern european
laborers in the german agricultural
industry
that said he believes french centralism
is the greatest hurdle to brittany's
progress
farmers fishermen laborers even
employers showed up the big
demonstration in
this is not the same as those social
movements that lead teachers to strike
or farmers to demonstrate
this is a whole region saying stop we
want a different system in this country
give us the means to make it happen
for decades but he now fears for his
future
the situation is very unsettling
if we close the factories we'll suddenly
have 8 000 people on the streets
the place will become an economic desert
a sense of unease is slowly spreading
through france's political ranks
the economic crisis
a weak president and rising unemployment
all play to the waiting hand of the
right-wing extremist fr nacional
we are fighting with people for the
rights of brittany
we don't want to abandon our region to
the full national which capitalizes on
people's misery to serve its own ends
i think the fall national is poisoned
for brittany and we are the antidote
but not everyone is convinced
including some of the workers at the
gates of the fish factory
i think they're just using what's
happening here it's really only about
politics
is
for now it's still unclear whether the
red caps protest is anything but a smoke
signal to paris